stop complaining about the quality of
our politicians it's your own fault
you pay peanuts and what do you expect
I'm not going to ask you to shed any
tears for the multi-millionaires who sit
around the cabinet table and I agree
that a reasonable person should be able
to live well on the MPS 79 thousand
pounds a year but here's the thing we
can say that people should enter public
service for the love of it but why would
a brilliant deputy headteacher force her
family to accept sacrifices for her own
political passions why should young
lawyers who worried about supporting
their aging parents have to tell them
they can't afford the best care home
because their Westminster doing God's
work our self-righteousness about
politicians earnings hasn't made them
more virtuous it made politics
predominantly the province of two types
of people those who can afford to do
anything they want and those who
probably couldn't get a job anywhere
else
the average grounded sensible person is
being priced out leaving a vacuum to be
filled by narcissists and incompetence
and that's killing our democracy gosh
that was quite punchy stuff from Trevor
Phillips Esquire not yet MP and you I
think that's um I think any person who's
stood for election would take offense at
what you've said because it's not just
narcissists and no hope as who stand for
Parliament but you do have a point
in that it's very expensive to stand for
office and even if you lose your seat
you spend tens of thousands of pounds if
you'd add in all the accommodation the
travel the expenses and the lost income
of actually giving up your life for what
can be five years - no - nurses seat I
think we should pay credit to these
people for willing to make that
sacrifice it's not just the very rich
but the truth is you're right you do
have to be well-off to be able to do it
because parties raise money for you to
be able to stand but they don't repay
your expenses as I disco
nice to clear protection and loss but on
the other hand the MP is actually earned
quite a good whack I don't think we're
paying peanuts and getting monkeys MP
salaries have risen over the last ten
years from sixty-four thousand to
seventy nine thousand that's a decent
wage yeah but what point I'm making and
I don't like this a conversation just
between the two of us because we're the
two here who have stood for election
we're all not 415 competence none of us
who got elected by the way but anyway
the point I'm really trying to make is
not that the sum is trivial I agree with
that
but the point is for the ordinary person
who used to be a person could become a
member of parliament they always have a
choice and the choice isn't just about
their virtue it is what do you say to
your family I want to make this I want I
want to become an MP and people might
say yeah that's a good thing but bear in
mind there are other calls on people's
responsibilities and my point is simply
but because we are now bearing down so
heavily both on the some and also what
empties can earn outside I think for the
ordinary person who could become a great
member Parliament they sit and they look
at their their families and they make a
choice daddy's fine and they're tending
to make that a choice
that leaves it only to the fanatics and
the rich that's all I make that's what
I'm making okay let's have a look at the
median household disposable income
according to the Office for National
Statistics in 2018-19 it was twenty nine
thousand four hundred pounds an MP
salary is not you know it's not normal
it's not a normal salary in fact an MP
salary puts them in the top 5% of
society so it's a straw man argument to
suggest that most people would look at a
salary of 80,000 pounds and go oh I'd
love to be an MP but that's not really
enough to live on
look the thing that stops people getting
into politics is the fact that politics
is one of those elite professions along
with the media and the judiciary and
others it is inaccessible partly for the
reasons that you're saying rate
which is that it cost so much just to
stand as a candidate never mind
even when partly because it's
inaccessible in terms of let me just
finish this idea of knowing how to be an
MP having the right connections having
the right conversations knowing the
right people that will enable that
pathway to be open to you that is
something that at the moment is a very
privileged pathway but Rachel I don't
want my Member of Parliament who is
making the most important decisions that
anybody makes in this country to be an
average person I want them to be better
than average and my point is the person
average in terms of income no
incapability knowledge exposed and a
person who has those capabilities has
better choices that's a point I'm making
if I'm if we're to strip away some that
the emotionally charged language from
your introduction this basic point that
you can either afford to do it because
you don't need income or the second type
of category said it's attracting which
is people that for whom it's all they've
ever known and all they can ever do I
think in essence you might be on to
something here if I can just have you
listen to this chap from the Alliance of
the Taxpayers Alliance Duncan Simpson
and then I'll come back off this many
high owners have already willfully given
up more money to join Parliament it's
also the case that a lot of MPs are
already on a salary which now is much
larger than what they would have earned
before being elected so in other words
what mp's earned before being elected
isn't necessarily a marker of how good
they'll be in the new job
but if MPs are apparently doing this out
of a sense of public duty then you know
the cash they earn should be a secondary
objective now there are people that will
add something I think some of the
professions you mentioned there are
people who for whom it would be a pay
cut I think you mentioned deputy
teachers that's the kind of person I
want to see more of them and see that
kind of now that's Rachel your your um
there was a part of your point actually
I think we reinforced Travis but when
you said that the inaccessibility
financially makes it difficult for some
people to join politics isn't that what
Trevor's saying I mean I kind of I heard
that in his
play the more and actually I think
they've if you're in the top five
percent of earners in this country
probably the thing that's making it less
accessible is not that you're paid less
that you're not paid enough we do need
to diversify it there's all kinds of
things standing in the way you look at
the life event of an MP you know I mean
they get they get dismissed a lot but I
think a lot of them are genuinely
hardworking people who care about their
constituents in the country but they you
know the the relation of relate excuse
me the rate of relationship breakdown is
hot is higher for parliamentarians the
rate of mental health no issues yeah
well they tend to be either aristocratic
in the sense that they don't need money
and they can just float and waft into
Parliament yeah or they tend to be
ideologues who are doing it because they
are dogmatically doggedly committed to
certain causes and that I think does
skew the debate it's so first of all I
don't agree in terms of inaccessibility
of politics I think that anyone can make
a decision to stand as an MP if that's
what they choose to do when it comes to
the cost and I know I'm taking you
slightly off topics I do apologize but
when it comes to the cost if one was to
stand under a political party most of
those costs were being cared by the
political party not by the individual so
I don't buy into this argument all the
time I know we're gonna debate this
later on but I don't buy into this
argument that we're restricting people
from entering something if that's what
they want to do but to make it back to
your central point I guess it's what do
you compare it to because politics is
not a job it's a life and you're
absolutely right it really is going to
impact on your relationships and your
family and if you're in the private
sector pet sector and you are deemed to
be relatively successful there is a
strong chance you will be earning a
decent amount of money and when you
start to compare like for like with
money purely from the private sector
going into this public sector it becomes
a very unattractive proposition if you
then go to your average household earner
and say you know you're earning 29 grand
a year what is a tier and in comparison
to you it's extraordinary but I think
it's a false comparison because if
someone wants to go into this field and
is willing to make the sacrifice it is
willing to do that then I do think they
should be rewarded properly and for what
it's worth I think that the MPs salary
in
Harrison's one is easy but the the best
comfort the proper comparison here would
be a general practitioner who can expect
these days in this country to earn more
than one hundred one hundred and twenty
thousand pounds a year if you're a
general practitioner but you're
interested in politics do you think
you'll do as much for the community
being a great doctor at you know fifty
sixty percent more than an MP or do you
want to give that up in order to be a
backbench MP with very little influence
I mean that's the point that the choice
I'm making we also members of parliament
are not average people we also have a
sir just as a factory we have the lowest
paid among the lowest paid Prime
Minister in the world you know in terms
of what we pay off yet